good morning everyone thank you for
joining us this is a really
important occasion for us the mobile
unit
uh if you get to have a chance to walk
inside it can hold up to 8 000
doses which is incredible that this will
be on the road
visiting the rural parts of our state
and all of you know that we've got some
pretty rural parts of our state
uh our tribal communities and so forth
but basically distributing the jansen
vaccine which is what i got
uh that's a single dose but it's going
to go a long way
towards equity in making this available
to everyone along the way
and we sincerely appreciate that today i
woke up it was a much better day it's
the first day that everyone
16 and over can get vaccines
everyone that is at least 16 years of
age can get a vaccine
time is now look online go to the
websites
make an appointment to get a vaccine
whichever one is available
that's what's going to get us out of
this pandemic and get us through this
entire situation
so we encourage everybody to get their
vaccine
and this mobile unit is going to make
that happen and also
to the folks that are running the
medical unit i mean they are going above
and beyond it is not the most
luxurious that you might see
uh they're gonna be roughing it for a
couple of weeks and we appreciate that
but they're doing what needs to be done
to take the vaccine out to the community
and to help the people that desperately
need it and uh
are waiting for it so with that i want
to thank you it takes a whole group of
people to make this happen
and you're seeing all of them here with
us today joining us at a special event
and
i'd be happy to take some questions and
we've got the national guard here too
i always want to acknowledge that our i
tell you
every time i turn to the national guard
they're there for us i mean to do
everything and
we should certainly thank you for what
you're doing if anybody has any
questions i'd be happy to take some
boys saying that is such a rural area
and there's small pockets everywhere was
this a concern of trying to how to how
to deal with girls
before this yeah it was definitely a
concern how to deal with the rules we
didn't have enough uh
sites in some of the rurals we didn't
have vaccinators in some of the rurals
you saw that esmeralda
they were having to go to all the other
communities in order to get vaccines so
this we're taking it out into the
communities
you're going to see a lot more of that
even in our urban communities
where we're going to be taking the
vaccines into the neighborhoods
everybody doesn't have the luxury of
having a vehicle to transport
or living on a public transportation
route so it's more difficult for those
folks
we need to do more to get it out in the
communities and this is one step along
that way
yeah as of this morning minorities are
still about half as likely to have
gotten the cobia vaccine
is there is
we are doing everything we possibly can
across the state a lot of that's left up
to the
local jurisdictions i've spoken to local
jurisdictions about getting out in the
communities
that's what i'm talking about we've
talked about getting it into some of our
senior centers
our local near abraha neighborhood
centers where they're more likely to be
if we have to take it
uh into the neighborhoods in terms of a
van going in there we're going to do
that
if we can do an accommodation with some
of our church facilities
to get it there where people can walk to
get the vaccine
and we're gonna do more to get that
there everybody has to have access
to the vaccine we're gonna do everything
we can to make sure that happens you're
seeing it a lot in
las vegas now where we took it into the
hotels to get it their workers who are
oftentimes minorities are going to have
the access to get it
so we're doing what we can to deliver
the vaccine where the people are
about how many vaccines per location and
how do you keep the vaccine
with this mobile trailer
thank you um so it's going to be about
250 per location
that will be done and there is a
refrigerator in this unit that will hold
up to 8 000 doses of the johnson product
so that's what we're going with
to do this i'm sure you don't want to do
multiple
we have enough vaccine with our state
allotments right now to be able to
handle all of the stops we're doing on
their mobile unit
that's where i don't um rodney
apologies how many stops are we doing
total in the northern route
um in the northern route uh we have 13
stops that are slated
in the northern route we have 13 stops
that are slated
throughout the month with the last stop
being in west windover
uh ending on may 1st
how important is this governor to have
something like this in the manpower to
continue to do this
because it's not a small field
it's it's incredibly important as i've
said all along we are now closer to the
end
than we are to the beginning of this
pandemic but this is taking us
steps closer to the end i mean you have
to get needles in arms
and they have this type of equipment to
be able to go out into these rural areas
and you folks know it you can drive like
we jumped inside you can drive
60 80 100 miles and see nothing in some
of these areas
to get to the next location so we're
taking the vaccine out there
and but for the fact that having this
trailer and this equipment it wouldn't
happen
so we're very very grateful and thankful
for it i feel blessed that we have it
and we have two of them that are going
to be working the way around the state
so
we're excited
hi so team rubicon is serving um
completely as support for the fema
vaccinations
we will travel with them through the 13
stops um
as support traffic control any sort of
back end support that they need we will
not have direct contact with any of the
patients or anyone getting the shots
but we will be here to support any way
we can
thanks for coming out everyone and as
you can see everybody
is playing a part in this whether it's
team rubicon it's fema
it's the vaccinators it takes a group of
people and a tremendous amount of
organization
we're thankful that we've got that to
move forward and hopefully that this
will get these vaccines out there very
very quickly and
i'm going to take the opportunity one
more time it's a very special day here
in nevada
anybody one more time anybody 16 years
of age or older
can make an appointment and go get their
vaccine to start the process to get your
vaccine
it's extremely important take advantage
of that now
so we can continue our road to recovery
thank you all very much